hello everyone and welcome to day three
of the Julius bird Generations cup and
we started off with a game between Arjun
irrigation and vasley vanchuk and it's
um it's a beautiful game it's a
wonderful miniature you guys will enjoy
it it's uh just something to uh to add
to every chess book like um we say so
many times when the games are so
aesthetically pleasing now let's check
it out Arjun has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 uh we have Knight to F6
and now Bishop to G5 he goes for the
trumpovsky attack uh vassal goes D6 we
have Knight the C3 and now Knight B to
D7 and now Pawn to E4 basically uh
transposing into some sort of a bishop
G5 type of black lines defense we have
E5 and now Knight to F3 we have Bishop
to E7 and Bishop the eve C4 so very very
standard ideas here C6 now trying to get
A5 and B5 in so of course A4 preventing
B5 and now both players just Castle
still castles castles and now point the
H6 challenging arjun's Bishop here
saying do you want to capture or do you
want to go back of course he's not going
to capture Bishop back to E3 and now
Rook to E8 and there are some games
where H3 and Bishop D2 were played but
here we have rookie one by Arjun and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so here Knight the
G4
going after the bishop here and Arjun
happily wastes a temple here by bringing
the bishop back to the starting square
but he will now of course kick away the
Knight so e captures and D4 by vassal
Knight captures on D4 and here Bishop to
F6 and this is a very very very uh
tricky position uh point being that the
Knight is still on the seven and the
bishop is not controlling the F5 Square
so of course the F5 square is now
available for arjun's Knight I will just
show a fun line as obviously something
you have to know if you're playing the
black line for example if in this
position you play Knight the C5 which is
uh which is very nice then what happens
is uh it's just very different because
the bishop Now controls the F5 square
and the standard idea of basically
refuting the Knight Wing and C5 B4 in
this position does not work because here
you would have Bishop H4 going after the
F2 pawn and okay you kick away the
bishop G3 but now Bishop to F6 and it
seems like you're giving up a piece but
really you're not because once you've
played B4 the Knight and C3 is no longer
defended so now if B captures and c5d
captors the Knight is attacked and has
to move let's say Knight F5 Queen
capture Sun D1 Rook captures and after
Bishop captures on f5e captures uh black
finishes with a nice Bishop captures and
C3 that's attacking the rook and you get
this position where
uh black is up upon and very very happy
with his position so uh Knight to C5
definitely uh much much a better idea or
even Knight D to E5 but the bishop to F6
allows the origin to really uh take
advantage of the position he plays
Knights there five now puts pressure on
the D6 spawn and it makes sense for
vasel to move the Knight so he plays
Knight to B6 again uh the E5 is the
correct Square for the Knight but he
plays Knight the B6 attacks the bishop
and now Arjun just uh
completely uh obliterate obliterates of
[ __ ] from the board he plays Bishop
captures on F7 with check and okay you
have to capture as The Rook would be
hanging so King captures now Queen
captures and G4 and now Bishop captures
in C3 B captures and C3 and while the
position is still playable but you have
to play it with Bishop captures and F5
if if you play this then Queen captures
with check Queen F6 and okay we trade
queens and now you get this position
where Arjun would be up a pawn he would
have a bishop against the Knight but
still he had he has a very uh damaged
Pawn structure uh okay white would be
better but he would have to really prove
that he can do something with this
position however after Queen to F6 uh it
is not possible to come back from this
because here Arjun plays Queen to H5
with check and now how do you play this
if you play G6 of course then just
Knight captures and H6 you lose the pawn
with the check and after King G7 you
just bring the queen back and everything
is perfectly fine the Knight is nicely
defended uh a black skin side is
completely ruined it will be a very very
easy win for white so instead after
Queen to H5 check King the f8 is played
by manchuk and now there is a beautiful
beautiful idea so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Arjun already
on move 17 uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding either of
the two ideas either Knight captures and
G7 or Knight captures on D6 as you are
truly an amazing tactician and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
this is what Arjun played Knight
captures and D6 in case you're wondering
if you capture here uh point is if Queen
captures then best shop captures on H6
wins the queen here and of course if you
don't capture uh with the queen if you
capture with the King then the rook and
E8 hangs so that's the problem but Arjun
goes for a different plan he plays
Knight captures on D6 now making Queen
captures impossible because the bishop
can trap the queen from this side as
well that's the power of the bishop you
know when you're wondering is the bishop
better than knight uh Bishop can do
quite a lot using the entire board
however he can only do it on one other
color squares Knight doesn't have that
that much Firepower however he can go
wherever he pleases just not very
quickly so here after Knight captures on
D6 Rook to E5 attacking the queen here
and now just Queen back to D1 we have
King the G8 moving the king away from
this nasty diagonal but now a
spectacular move by origin just taking
just absolutely taking the most uh out
of the position Ponte A5 spectacular the
Knight has no squares uh of course all
of these squares are covered and if you
go to the seven dingest Knight captures
on C8 removes the defender of the Knight
then Queen picks up the Knight
absolutely crushing so Knight the D5 is
played trying to give up the material
this way but first Knight captures on C8
Knight captures on C3 at least you will
do something before you before you give
up material but now Queen D7 defends the
Knight here Knight captures on e4 and
now Bishop to E3 uh there there's really
no move here you are just
without without any good ideas here and
now after Queen F7 Arjun very very
happily trades Queen captures an F7 King
captures and now he finishes again with
the absolutely most precise move Bishop
to D4 and he was in this position on
move 25 that Vaseline when Chuck
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here in modern times a
winning uh 25 or under moves is
considered a miniature so definitely you
know well deserved for for uh especially
when playing against uh a genius like
like um Evancho cure and this also means
that Arjun extends his lead as he was
leading going into the third day ahead
of Magnuson and pragnananda so we'll see
if he can take it all the way but yeah
here he resigned because the Rook is
attacked once The Rook moves doesn't
really matter where you're just gonna
play Rook captures on e4 and that's it
now if Rook captures a nice Fork picks
up the Rook as well not King E6 capture
Syria Alpha bishop and the Knight and
even if you don't accept this for
example
if rookie 8 and row captures and e4u
could also capture the Knight here
doesn't matter you just trade captures
captures you pick up the A7 pawn and
still you are up a full piece of course
this is completely winning so uh
eventually does not want to play this he
says I'm I'm just uh you know I'm done
uh good game uh young young sir and he
resigns uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and that maybe
you've um uh you know the the black line
defense and also the if a similar
position arises from the trumpovski like
he did here can be a bit of a problem
you know for players there are some
ideas like you can counter every day for
A5 and then you know maybe some uh just
the standard moves but also you can see
that if black doesn't really know how to
re-maneuver those Knights back into the
game uh you can uh fall victim to a very
sharp attack very early on uh sure
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
big congratulations to our June for such
a spectacular Victory uh I would like to
thank Marcelo de Barros yeah Paul
certanovican is uh domazzi Francis air
and guia para la Paz interior for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this spectacular event uh until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day